[Music]
[Music]
because
every day
for some people this day is not good
for some people this day is the last one
i
speak today now about
my citizens citizens of ukraine who are
defending
by paying the ultimate price
they defending freedom
i'm very happy
what i've seen here now
and heard here now i'm very glad
to sense this mood
the uniting unifying mood i'm happy that
we have unified today all of you all the
countries of the european union
but i did not know but this is that this
is the price they will have to pay and
it's a tragedy for our for me
for every ukrainian tragedy for our
state i mean this pro this high price
very high price
thousands of people who were killed
two revolutions
one wall
and five days of full-scale invasion of
the russian federation
you know
i'm not i don't read off the paper off
the sheet
because the
paper phase
in this in the life of my country has
ended
now we're dealing with reality we're
dealing with
killed people real life you know
and you know
i believe that
we today
we're giving lives for
values for rights for freedom for the
desire to be equal as much as you are
we are
giving away our best people
the strongest ones the most value-based
ones ukrainians are incredible
and
very often we love to say
that we will win over everyone
and i'm very happy that you are not only
talking about it but you can see that
and we indeed we will overcome everyone
and i'm sure i'm convinced
there is an expression
ukrainian
choice your european choice of ukraine
that's we're striving for and that's
what we're going to and we went to
so i would like
to hear that from you to us
we could hear
um the the the
ukrainian
choice for europe from you i have
have
some time off here because we have
breaks between the missile strikes and
bombardments and this morning was a very
tragic one for us
two cruise missiles hit haruki
the city
which is located to the borders of the
russian federation there were always
many russians there
and they're always friendly there were
warm relations there
more than 20 universities are there
it's the city that has the largest
number of universities in our country
the youth is bright smart there
the people who gathered there all the
time and was gathering there all the
time for celebrating all the
celebrations at on the largest square in
our country the
freedom square and
and this is the largest square in europe
and that's true this is called the
freedom square can you imagine this
morning two cruise missiles
hit this freedom square
dozens of killed
ones this is the price of freedom
we are fighting
just for our
land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all life cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's gonna break us
we're strong we're ukrainians
we have a desire to see our children
alive
i think it's a fair one
yesterday 16 children were killed
again and again president putin is going
to say that is some kind of operation
and we are heating a military
infrastructure where our children what
kind of military factories do they work
at
what tanks are they going with or
launching cruise missiles he killed 16
people just yesterday
our people are very much motivated very
much so we are fighting
for our rights
for our freedoms
for life for our life and now
we're boring
and this is the highest of our
motivation
but we are fighting
also
to be
equal members
of europe
i believe that
today
we
are showing everybody that's exactly
what we are
the european union
is going to be much stronger with that
so that's for sure
without you
ukraine
is going to be lonely lonesome
we have proven our strengths
we have proven
that
as at a minimum
we are exactly the worst the same as you
are
so do prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
do prove that you indeed are europeans
and then
life will
win over death and light will win over
darkness glory be to ukraine
you